have you ever considered changing your
career rethink your future to be happier
happier nice Wow
it's never too late to reassess folks
we're in the Toyota greenroom with the
lovely talented and ever brilliant CBS
News business analyst still Schlesinger
who has some tips to help you with your
professional life she knows everything
about anything involving business am i
embarrassing you no no I would say
anything with a dollar sign and you know
what's funny we're talking about career
this is the time of year a lot of people
live well my kids are back in school
they're settled this is a really good
time to focus on yourself because you've
got this great period where before the
Christmas season comes upon you focus on
you yeah a lot of empty nesters out
there may have stayed a lot of mothers
or fathers may have chosen to stay at
home with the kids what do they do well
I think if you're coming into the labor
force to begin with and it's we've had a
gap and it doesn't have to be you know
25 years it could be even just five
years the best thing that you really
need to do is start really conducting
some in-depth research now the good news
is that maybe before you left on your
break there wasn't as there weren't as
many resources but now you can go into a
number of career search websites and you
can go in there and say what is this
thing what is it like to be a broadcast
journalist what is it like to be a
financial analyst what is it like to be
a healthcare worker and there's a lot of
information out there and what you
really want to do is try to get an idea
of what's going on in your desired job
industry and figure out if you've got
some skills that could match up with
that type of job and I mean a lot of
people are going back to work they don't
want to necessarily make the most amount
of money but they do want to find a good
fit and I think the research part of the
process is incredibly important how do
they pivot I mean I know social media
can help and that sort of launching of
the new career but they have to be
clever about it yeah I mean I think that
the word networking gets overused
it's instead of saying networking
because a lot of people say I'm shy hey
networking that's horrible we just want
to talk to people yeah doesn't we used
to do talk to people and I know that it
sounds kind of horrible to say oh I got
to go on LinkedIn and now I got a really
look at this but you really just want to
talk to a number of different people you
know I have a friend of mine who worked
in a interesting field she worked at
Christie's which is an auction house and
she found herself dealing with a lot of
places that were donating things she's
not wouldn't be interesting to get
involved in philanthropy to be on the
other side she started doing a lot of
research and all of a sudden she calls
me up and she says to me would you talk
to me I said well what do I know anyway
we had coffee and we actually brainstorm
a little bit and it turns out I didn't
know something I didn't know someone who
could help her out so you really want to
have these quick coffee dates with
people who you say I don't want a job I
don't know about this or what do you
think or can we talk a little bit you
would be surprised how many leads you
get from face-to-face interactions
anyone you could possibly think of it's
a fresh perspective it really is sort of
a new lens on an old problem exactly and
you know when you think about networking
the one thing that I really want to warn
people about is networking is tough
because you are asking something of
somebody don't ask too much and don't be
a nudge as my mother always likes to say
no one likes a nudge even though she's a
great note I'm but you know in other
words that if you if someone's not
responding it's okay go on to the next
person don't like keep following up and
following up if you're not getting a
response but do try to find someone who
knows somebody hey Michelle I see on
LinkedIn that you know Brandon you
introduced me to him because it would be
better if I could come through an
introduction rather than going cold and
straight to him yeah clean up your
social media - oh boy so young people
I'm sorry to say that this digital life
is unforgiving so when you think about
what you want to present to the world
those old pictures of you and your
sorority sisters or your frat boy
friends may not be appropriate you may
want to really check the privacy
settings
may want to turn things off to the
public you really should be careful all
major companies are now looking at your
social media platforms to get a better
sense of who you are so put yourself in
their shoes what I really want the
Michelle who is dancing with her friends
cup of booze in her hand looking like
she's living large
maybe not that's not the best look or
the Jill Schlesinger who does some
things sometimes so you really do want
to clean that up so for folks I know I
get this all the time for folks who love
their job but they just want a kick
upstairs maybe you know promotion a
little bit more money what's your best
advice for them without being too pushy
well I think that there's something
interesting that happens in many
organizations and that is when you're
homegrown when you come up from the
bottom sometimes you don't make as much
money as the person who comes in five
six years later right and I think that
that's incredibly important so what do
you want to do you want to take an
inventory of what you've done in this
company now for some people it's a
little bit easier you could say well I'm
a salesperson this is how much money I
brought in in sales or I'm a trader on
Wall Street some things are quantifiable
but don't worry because there are
probably many things you do for the
organization that maybe have helped save
money have made your boss look really
good get that information together
do some research how much are people in
your field earning it's a tight labor
market and companies do want to hold on
to their best employees
now you're gonna schedule time talk to
your boss and you're gonna say look at
this stuff I would like to have a
conversation with you here's what I've
done and I understand that in this field
there is a range of what people are
earning so let's just make it up let's
pretend that you're making $50,000 a
year you find out that the range for
your job is really 60 to 65 thousand
dollars a year so when you may say to
your bosses I understand that there is a
range for the job I'm being underpaid
and now you want to have your boss sit
with that don't put the number
if the boss says what's the range you
say well given my experience what I
think I understand is that I'm at there
that's the in within the range and
sixty-five thousand is the right number
and what you want to do is you want to
rank you want to you want to anchor the
range so you might say sixty-five to
seventy-five thousand dollars and I'm at
the low Emmit that I'm at the 65 or you
might say exactly this seventy you know
what I said it too high has to be
reasonable with the range should be the
range should be you want to anchor
yourself to the number you want but when
you give a range what's interesting is
bosses tend to say oh she's not asking
for the top end of the range she's
asking for didn't the range yeah and be
smart about it
yeah the boss says no let's just say you
know what things are tough here I know
the economy is doing well I know that
the labor market here in this company
we're not doing that you say okay great
maybe there's some non direct
compensation I can get can I get an
extra week of vacation can I get three
more holidays off can I do this can I do
that
and also say that you understand don't
be a baby and say can we meet again in
six months to discuss yeah that can be
used on the issue of equal pay as well
folks don't splurge when you do get that
raise I know that's no no when it comes
to your advice yeah when you if you're
lucky enough so let's say that either
you get a new job so you haven't been
making money for a while you get a new
job or you've gotten a raise the first
thing you want to make sure you've done
is use that money constructively that
could mean you put money into that
retirement plan it's a really great
thing to do is to bump up your
retirement plan contributions from the
raise automatically before the money
starts coming up so yeah really good one
I'd do it and then I like hide money
exactly would have to hide whatever
trash you can play on yourself happy to
encourage you to do it to learn more
business and financial tips from Jill
just visit Jill on money.com
as well as folks thanks for joining us